richtig krass iBM hat gerade die neue
Quantum safe Technologie vorgestellt
aber bevor wir erklären wie das aussieht
machen wir noch mal einen kleinen
Schritt zurück was ist das Problem
vielleicht können Quantencomputer bald
Aufgaben lösen die bisher ungelöst
blieben an sich geil aber diese
Fortschritte bringen auch
Sicherheitsrisiken mit sich
Quantencomputer könnten in der Lage sein
die am weitesten verbreiteten
Sicherheitsprotokolle der Welt alle zu
knacken und um sich davor zu schützen
kann man mit den Tools von IBM jetzt
Schwachstellen in der eigenen
Kryptografie finden und diese damit
Quanten sich machen zusätzlich hat IBM
eine Quantum safe Roadmap veröffentlicht
um Kunden bei diesem sicherheitsübergang
zu unterstützen sie definiert wie wir
immer fortschrittlichere Quantum safe
Technologien erreichen könnten schon
2016 wurden mögliche Algorithmen für
quantensichere Verschlüsselung gesucht
drei der vier ausgewählten Standards
wurden jetzt bei IBM entwickelt deswegen
finde ich es